california governor gavin newsom earning
high praise from controversial lada
george gascon over his new
gun control laws the fellow progressive
thanking the governor for his tough
limits on firearms claiming quote these
sensible measures will stop the deadly
epidemic of gun violence it comes as
gascone faces growing outrage over his
soft on prime policies releasing
criminals who've gone on to commit
even more violent crimes like this
convicted murderer released just six
years
into a 50-year sentence and now already
back behind bars on gun and drug charges
reuben report host and former la
resident dave rubin is here to react
dave thanks so much for being here thank
you peter you can call me proud new
floridians proudly they can put that
underneath i said how is florida you
said i'm never leaving never
buried in the everglades this is it for
me you don't miss it one bit i do not
and it's exactly because of those two
guys i mean the policies of newsom
gascon garcetti and la
everything they've done up in san
francisco it's like if you want to be
around homelessness if you want crime
everywhere if you want a defunded police
if you want to catch and release
criminals the list goes on and on then
you should go to california and don't
forget all the high taxes that you get
to pay and the services that simply
don't work or you can move here to
florida where there is a sense that
freedom exists that individual rights
exist the law and order exists and all
those things so the choice is pretty
obvious actually it feels like it ends
up permeating everything right so so
there's an uncertainty and uneasiness in
an environment of a place like los
angeles where when you when you go to
somewhere like florida where you at
least understand that there is law and
order and understanding of consequences
it it trickles throughout everything oh
it trickles through everything because
people think this is just policy like oh
if i just stay out of a high crime
neighborhood or if i stay away from the
homeless shelter or something like that
that i'll be okay but actually it's the
spirit of the people i mean one of the
things that's going on here in florida
that's so awesome that i'm seeing here
at turning point uh and all over the
state is that people are excited to be
here you know you meet people hey
welcome to florida we're so happy to
have you they they are proud of the
american flag they're proud that this
state and and especially our governor
has stood up against fouchy and
lockdowns and all of those things where
california you know it's sort of
becoming almost like a zombie movie
where you feel like everybody's just
kind of going along the the light in
their eyes is kind of not there because
they are accepting that the government
at any time can say to them hey we're
locking you down hey we're releasing
criminals on the streets your life has
very little to do with the consequences
that you put into the world it's just
that the machine is going to decide what
to do at any point and it's and it's
just so obvious i mean i would welcome
anyone watching this spend a weekend in
florida spend a weekend in cali and and
figure out which one is better yeah
the weather is what kept people there
for the longest time look it's humid
here and i'm a little dewy but it's all
right man it's all right hey i'll take
it for sure now you're about to hit the
stage yes uh at about 8 30. so by the
way foxnation foxnation.com you can
watch all of the speeches here at the
student action summit dave rubin being
one of them what are you going to share
with this young audience well it's going
to be a little bit about that because i
think my life is a perfect example of
what's going on in the country right now
is we realize that red states and blue
states are very different that you can
live in a place that's more in line with
your values i moved to florida on
december 17th 2021 it is etched in my
mind forever and i in many ways feel
like i'm living in a new country and i'm
and i'm here to fight to keep it free
and that's really going to be the
message and then with that is just sort
of the message of what i would say is
sort of a new conservatism which is
really we believe in reality we believe
in sanity we believe in the things that
we all used to believe you know say five
years ago like two plus two is four and
boys and girls are different and being
not racist is good enough stuff that we
all accepted that now is up in the air
again i i think that's a very wide tent
conservative movement right now and and
you don't even have to call it
conservative it's just a move there's
there's one party that's roughly sane
and there's one party that's completely
bananas and that actually is a perfect
metaphor for cali in florida as well
it's true the sanity party the sanity
movement it is really a back to basics
moment you could call it the sanity
party it kind of works here in florida
you got it it does kind of work if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell